ces deux hommes ont un membre de leur
famille hospitalisée depuis le mois de
mai pour un grave problème de santé d'al
jean bernard qui à 43 ans le foie de
monsieur hainard est tellement mauvais
état qu'une transplantation semble seul
traitement possible
dans son dossier médical il est écrit
que ce n'est pas bien aux candidats une
greffe ses chances de survie sont très
minces pour éviter le pire son frère son
beau frère et d'autres membres de la
famille se porte volontaire pour un
éventuel don d'organes est prête à
donner une partie de votre foi
absolument à ce que vous pensez qu'il
vaut la peine d'être vu absolument
absolument c'est mon frère on va falloir
pas juste arrêter comme ça le problème
c'est que monsieur nar souffrait
d'alcoolisme depuis 2007 que c'est
l'alcool qui a détruit son foie et qu'il
n'a jamais été sobre durant une période
prolongée
pour cette raison on refuse de lui
greffer une nouveau fois qu'on le
considère inadmissible
à une greffe en raison du fait qu'il est
conscient est attribuée à une
consommation d'alcool et on lui impose
en fait là d une période de sobriété de
six mois en dehors d'un milieu
hospitalier avant de pouvoir considérer
le qui met en scène deux fois non pas
malgré
décédé avant leur fin ces périodes de
sobriété exactement depuis trois mois
monsieur nar qui traitait au centre
hospitalier lexus a essuyé plusieurs
refus d'abord auprès du cuse où on peut
lire dans son dossier la politique du
cuse hymne c'est qu'une maladie non
traitée est hors de contrôle est
incompatible avec une transplantation
sont d'aussi a ensuite été présenté à
cinq centres de transplantation canada
même résultat no name is id nous aussi
on a contacté nous mêmes on l'a contacté
des centres de transplantation partout
au canada alberta en ontario ils ont dit
la même chose
il faut attendre six mois il faut être
sous contrôle
même si son état était grave
rendu à la fin il dit non l'avocat de la
famille ne croit que cette approche
médicale est trop stricte qu'on juge son
client uniquement sur son comportement
passé spectacle qui dit n'avoir à sa
face même quand on compare avec d'autres
éléments qui ne sont pas pris en compte
fait des choix alimentaires et ont mené
à la perte de son fois votre ami c'est
ben grubb deux fois cette torontoise est
du même avis son mari alcoolique est
mort en 2010 après s'être fait refuser
une greffe de donneurs vivants elle
conteste maintenant la règle devant les
tribunaux
et ce design assez
[Musique]
bas
et je retourne puis mais pour la famille
nar le temps file sans rire du fois ils
vont probablement perdre leurs frères
nous sommes conscients que ça peut pas
demander aussi hockey est à dire d autre
chose qui peut qui peut venir on sait
pas ok mais le chose qui est difficile
c'est qu' aucune personne de donne même
de chance pour être considéré comme un
candidat ici norma grondin radio canada
montréal